so as we continue our series on the
books of doom
issue number three is well it's pretty
monumental is pretty awesome and the
reason why is it shows us that there's a
much bigger world out there that Victor
Von Doom was simply just not aware of
and the reason why we know that is after
his time in America after he had scarred
his face or believed to have scarred his
face he basically left the United States
now something that I want to point out
here is this era in human history takes
place around the time of the Cold War
maybe shortly after the end of World War
two so we're talking about late 1940s
early 1950s but were not quite into the
1960s yet and so this point was where
the United States and Russia were
basically engaging in a weapons race
more or less now in the real world here
there was a space race and we had
conflicts like Afghanistan and Korea and
Vietnam and Marvel Comics you had those
two but it was also extended to
superheroes in might have Captain
America because dr. Abraham Erskine had
died the United States under the
direction of sublime which is an entity
that I have a video on they had
basically begun the process of trying to
recreate the Super Soldier program the
problem is the formula of dr. Abraham
Erskine could not be duplicated but
because of the success of Captain
America Russia had tried to do the same
thing now this is where the story of
Colossus comes into play of course as we
know Colossus has the ability to immerse
himself in organic metal skin Colossus
was sought after by the Russians for
their own Super Soldier program their
own superhero type program the issue
here is that Doctor Doom was pursued as
well now this was likely because of the
fact Doctor Doom was part of the
American program and so even if the
Russians don't know that he has powers
they know he was working with the
American military-industrial complex and
so he likely has knowledge that would
prove to be very valuable to them now
while Doctor Doom has escaped to Eastern
Europe and has tried to lose himself in
Eastern European cities he's still
plagued with nightmares of Mephisto
who's taunting him about how is his
mother's soul is being held captive all
those kinds of things and the issue here
is that Victor Von Doom is kind of stuck
in a weird situation he can't sleep
because he drives him insane with these
nightmares but he can't really stay
awake too often because his body needs
rest and so he's kind of whining going
down as this path of mental instability
and this is what he says you know he
says these sleepless nights this tired
tireless
work is kind of beginning to have a
mental toll on him now the other half of
this is a guy named Otto now Otto only
appears in this in this part of the
story but he's extremely important
because he will be the catalyst that
sets Victor Von Doom
on the path of actually becoming Doctor
Doom with the metal uniform and engaging
in the kind of alchemy that were used to
seeing him engage in but Otto as he's
presented here by Ed Brubaker is
initially just a drunk guy he just hangs
out around the home of Victor Von Doom
and various taverns and so on and so
forth and doom really considers him more
of a nuisance than anything else but I'd
like you to keep him in the back of your
head because he will be important as we
get towards the end of this but what
doom tells us is that most of his
morning's again were spent just kind of
roaming around the city basically just
sort of killing time in truth he doesn't
really have a direction in his life he
doesn't he's not really going anywhere
he's just kind of living one day to the
next and just occupying a space in the
world his nights again are filled with
tireless work but even the work that he
does isn't going anywhere he's literally
building and breaking down and
rebuilding the same piece of equipment
over and over again trying to make it
perfect which he knows is something that
he'll never be able to do not because
he's not intelligent enough but because
the object has reached its full build
it'll never be anything better than what
it already is but what he also says is
that he's being watched because the
Russians were looking to take the
Americans over in terms of military
intelligence in terms of superpowers so
on and so forth and Victor Von Doom was
initially being pursued now again doom
isn't really invoking magic here because
they can't imagine that were used to
seeing doom use right now with sorcery
and so on and so forth that comes later
the kind of magic he used when he was
chasing off the forces of the Baron
we're a combination of technology as
well as the books that belong to his
mother but he currently doesn't have
those books with him and so he usually
just kind of uses hand-to-hand combat to
fend off these guys and this is what
happens you know of course they tell him
that the Russian government would be
interested in having Doom work for them
and it's really not a request so much as
it is an instruction but doom is able to
fight them off using a couple of devices
that you created that are explosive and
scare the Wits out of these KGB
operatives and so what he tells them is
that if they come looking for him again
a lot more than they bargained for it'll
likely result in their own deaths
and so to dooms eyes he wasn't really
being pursued by them at least he didn't
see them anymore and this is kind of
saying something because dooms very keen
again in terms of his intelligence in
terms of his awareness of his
surroundings he usually always knows
what's going on and so if he can't see
them it means either they're simply not
watching him or they're being extremely
sneaky and so what happens is we pick up
on a random day in the town square and
he comes back into contact with valerian
now again for those of you guys who were
just joining us valaria was the
childhood love interest of Victor Von
Doom and she made him feel like his life
could have been better than what it was
and she represented a better life for
him she represented hope in a lot of
different ways a hope that he felt he
had lost following the death of both of
his parents and so while the two of them
begin to sort of rekindle their
experience together doom is sort of torn
here on 1/2
he knows his life isn't going anywhere
and so he wants to immediately dismiss
her but on the other half he meets her
like he needs her there you know he
needs her to sort of make him feel a
little more complete now what she also
does is fill in the gaps
she says that of course the caravan had
continued on you know even after doom
had left that one of the guys Bors had
sort of stepped in as leader in his
place but because of the fact that the
Russians were pursuing a Victor Von Doom
after he had left America that the Baron
under the direction of the Russians had
basically begun a series of sweeping
campaigns through these Romani
territories and eventually found the
caravan and had basically set fire to it
killed a multitude of its people for the
purpose of trying to find Victor Von
Doom interrogating who he could when he
could and so what happens is she
eventually came across a guy named
Christos and Christos was a fortune
teller who made the case that Victor Von
Doom is a guy that someone doesn't want
to be found
now the aspects of fortune-telling that
are given to us here are a little shady
and in fact we'll find out was a little
more going on behind the scenes with
Christos than what was originally told
to us but he says that Victor Von dooms
mind is in shambles he's simply trying
to find his way in the world he doesn't
really have a direction but she
ultimately pointed him in the direction
of where he was last seen which was in
this town in eastern europe and so
seeking him out the two eventually fell
back into contact again and this
rekindled some romance between the two
and in fact they actually act this
romance out between the two of them but
for doom it's more of a feeling of
completion as opposed
simply just you know fulfilling physical
needs and so what is up happening is
that as the two of them continue about
their normal day eventually valaria runs
into auto now Victor Von Doom is cruel
to auto in the sense that he's
dismissive he doesn't really want to
have any interest in him he usually
chases him off but for valaria autos is
a very sweet guy you know he does what
he can he's a drunk kind of wasting his
life away but he's not a terrible human
being and so this is really valaria
beginning to see the darker side of doom
in terms of his dismissiveness in the
sense that is just really care for how
it is that he's passing himself off but
what happens is that as the two of them
are engaging in a conversation as
they're talking about how Doom treats
Auto they're suddenly met by the arrival
of KGB soldiers now one of these
soldiers takes valaria hostage and what
he says is that Doom has a choice either
he can watch valaria die or he can agree
to work for the Russians and so what we
do or at least what Ed Brubaker does is
he gives us the back story to this he
give us the back half to this and he
tells us that Christos was not a fortune
teller
instead Christos simply didn't want to
die he appealed to the to the Baron and
to the Russians and agreed to give them
away to find Victor Von Doom and so what
he did is he went to malaria and told
her where he believed Victor Von Doom
was of course using the information
given to him by the Russians and due to
their previous encounter and had allowed
valerian assembly travel off to meet
Victor Von Doom after which the Russians
and the KGB had followed her and
eventually we end up in this current
circumstance right now now this is
something I'd like you to keep in the
back of your head in terms of how we're
seeing Christos here because in a lot of
ways he looks remorseful and he looks
like he's a prisoner of sorts but what
happens here is Victor Von Doom
initially wants to keep Valerius safe
the problem is he's not going to be able
to protect her and himself against these
soldiers who were using machine guns and
the soldier I guess the KGB agent that
currently has a gun to her head but
before any of them can do anything
valaria is immersed in a protective
field and there are a series of
explosions on the street and when
everything begins to come clear we
actually find that Otto has been shot
and is in the process of dying but what
he says is that he's not just a drunk
guy he's been watching Victor Von Doom
now the reason for this is because he
hails from a temple in Tibet Otto was
told that a time would come when
man with a hidden face who was trying to
hide from the world would make its
presence known and eventually become the
leader of Otto's order and so Otto's
goal was to monitor Victor Von Doom to
see a few as that guy and then at some
point in the future basically get Victor
Von Doom to move to this temple in Tibet
the problem is because of the fact that
Otto's been killed he passes on this
message to Victor Von Doom but also says
that the people in this temple are some
of the best teachers in the world when
it comes to practicing alchemy and
sorcery and so he says that this is
dooms legacy this is dooms path he
cannot deny who it is that he's meant to
be and so he tells doom go to the temple
in Tibet go there learn your destiny and
then become who it is that you're meant
to be and so for doom this is basically
an ending this is him walking away from
Valerius him leaving his past life
behind and he ends up moving away from
the scenario in his entirety and
travelling to the temple in Tibet in
order to officially become Doctor Doom
but with that being said we're gonna
bring this video to an end if you guys
enjoyed it let me know leave a like and
hit that sub button to become part of
the Rob core and yeah I will see you
guys in the next video peace
[Music]
you